[Music]
jennifer is in houston texas hi jennifer
how are you
i'm doing fabulous um i'm calling i have
a 15 year old son uh he has a job at
chick-fil-a
um so he's got some paychecks coming in
um he took your class
and both my teenagers took the high
school class at home we just bought the
package so he has all the tools
we've got them enveloped we require them
to save 40
of anything that they make uh and then
they pay their tithe
so there's another 50 percent that he
just wants to blow
on video games and video stuff
uh which i hate and it's
problems with we have to we have to keep
him under so many hours otherwise his
attitude has to be put in check
so would you advise we just let him blow
all that money
or at what age do you start giving them
more choices to either be successful or
to fail
[Music]
well here's here's the deal jennifer for
me i'm probably more like your son
i was a spender i didn't really keep
track of a lot
i kind of just i wasn't that great with
money as a teenager
and mom and dad i mean you guys i would
say had levels of accountability that we
kind of had to meet but overall there
was a level of us just making mistakes
and for me i appreciated that because i
would rather
learn from my own mistakes with the
money i've earned
when i make a mistake i feel it so much
more than obviously if you were just
handed money
and you made a mistake with that money
and so for me learning from those
mistakes they were inexpensive there was
a level of safety because i was under
mom and dad's roof versus the first time
i made a mistake
was out on my own so i would say there's
a
there's a balance of allowing him to
feel the pain
and the mistakes that he's making if if
you consider buying all the video games
a mistake
um but he's already still he's saving
and he's giving
he's doing all three that we we really
recommend which is giving saving and
spending so
the fact that he's doing all three the
spending is the one that obviously he
will
learn a lot from and where you easily
can make mistakes yeah i think there's a
probably for all of us with teenagers
there's a fine line between nagging the
crud out of them
and making sure they leave home with the
leave home with the skills to be an
adult our friend andy anders says we're
not trying to raise great kids we're
trying to raise kids who become great
adults
and there's a difference and so my job
if i'm you if i'm you i'm talking to him
and saying my job
is not necessarily to judge whether
buying video games is stupid or not i
kind of think it is
but it's not my job to do that my job is
to make sure as your mom
or your dad that you have spending
saving and giving skills now
that means that if you continue to
completely waste
your spending money then we're going to
talk about it
that you're wasting that because i want
you to get it that you're wasting that
i'm probably going to let you do it
but i want you to get it because honey
if you don't get your spending under
control
you're going to be a 45 year old doofus
as a husband
right okay yeah because next time i mean
when he's 45 it'll be bass boats
right so then i shouldn't be concerned
about like too much video games about
controlling how much he plays if you
want oh well now controlling how much he
plays and controlling screen time is a
whole nother discussion
but that's not having to do with
spending that's not having to do with
money that's got to do with his
behaviors
yeah yeah yeah there is all kinds of
data coming out
on kids and screens and none of it's
good
right right the amount of kid screen
time and video game time kids are doing
is damaging a generation there's no
question about that
and uh we did it but we parked them in
front of a television
and popped in little mermaid you know
but that was different than
they live on their mama's phone when
they're three years old man
i mean it's there and there's data all
kinds of data
the level of porn addiction at 15 years
old by too much online screen time is
out the man the statistics are scary
so that's a whole different discussion
i'm going to limit that just because i
want his brain to work
i don't want his brain i don't even
become a vegetable but i'm not limiting
that because of the speed
i'm sorry at what point do i say you can
save if you want or you don't have to
save like
oh you need to you you're always going
to save you're always going to spend
and you're wisely and you can blow some
of it and you're always going to give
those are skills you have to do while
you live here you also have to bathe
and you also have to do your homework
and brush your teeth
these are skills you will need as an
adult
thank you hey hang on we're going to
send you a copy of the book rachel and i
did that was a number one called smart
money smart kids
teaching kids to handle money
there's another thing that goes on
rachel with this it's worth discussing
and she was not doing this but sometimes
you and i hear
that parents don't feel like they have
the right to tell a 16 year old
what to do with money they quote unquote
earned
in this case working at chick-fil-a now
she was not suffering from that problem
thank goodness okay but i i just want to
encourage parents
you not only have the right to do that
you have the obligation it's called
parenting
yeah yeah we've heard people say well
it's their money
like no they're living under your home
so your rules
are over the money that they earn at
chick-fil-a yeah i mean that's
that's an element of responsibility that
a parent has to have yeah it's
i mean is if you're if you're not we're
not suggesting you scarf their money and
buy cocaine for yourself with it that's
not the point
you know i mean you don't have this is
not you're stealing your child's money
but this idea that you're not in control
of your own household
and that you're not that the inmates are
running the asylum you're not
they're making the decisions i can't
tell him what to do with that money you
can buy
it's his money well yes by god you can
tell them what to do as a matter of fact
you're supposed to tell them what to do
that's why god made you in charge of
that house hypothetically you should be
yeah so
that's a big deal so you need to make
them
if you can't persuade them brush their
teeth
you need to make them if you can't
persuade them
not cuss out their elders you need to
make them
if you can't persuade them save give
spend and work
yeah yeah absolutely these are life
skills you need to exist on this planet
and prosper and uh so that that's what
smart money smart kids was about and
that whole
video curriculum that whole curriculum
is part of ramsey plus
that rachel did and i was in a little
bit of it but
mainly it came off of that book smart
money smart kids and it's all about
teaching
you guys teaching your kids how to
handle money what you do when they're
four
what you do when they're 14 what you do
when they're 18.
and it makes it makes a lot of
difference yeah the subject with
with money and parents i mean it's a
it's one of those discussions that can
feel
uh intimidating it's one of those
discussions that parents don't feel like
they have the margin to even
partake in because they're trying to
just keep the lights on in their own
home like i mean there's
there's so many dynamics but i think
bringing in money the conversation how
you handle it and the ebb and flow of
life
making it a part of the rhythm is
something that's really important as a
parent and to be open
and honest and and have discussions and
have questions and talk about it like
it's not a
it's not an evil subject so engage it as
a parent and the more your kids can
handle
their own money and learn to give it
save it and spend it for what they've
earned
that's what changes in their brain i
mean it's so it clicks it clicks with
them and it clicks so early
the old the old saying is teach someone
the value of a dollar
that's the old saying but what it
amounts to is teach them to value things
that matter
like i grew up in a neighborhood where
the majority of the men in the
neighborhood
their day job they worked with tools
blue collar jobs
in one way or another and so tools were
sacred
if you borrowed a guy's wrench his pair
of pliers
and you didn't take it back that was a
death sentence
in our neighborhood because that man
made his living
with that those tools and or did his
side job
with those tools and tools made the
world go around in that and so
knowing the value of tools and that they
are sacred
hand tools in that setting and so like i
rented a chainsaw one time from a rental
place
and i sharpened it before i took it back
and the rental guy goes
who does that well guys that grew up in
my neighborhood
because you take everything back better
than you found it it's full of gas
and you know it it's sharpened yeah and
you don't it's not damaged and
because tools are sacred and so the
money is that way in that sense you
treat it
with its value and it gives the kid up
an operating paradigm this is the dave
ramsey show